chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
c'est audition donc se déroule dans le
cadre de l'examen donc par le Sénat de
la proposition de loi qui vise
l'encadrement de l'influence commerciale
et qui vise à lutter contre les dérives
des influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux
la PPL dite influenceurs nous avons donc
le plaisir d'auditionner cet après-midi
madame Magali Berdah fondatrice de
l'agence d'influence d'influenceurs
chona events et professionnel français
du secteur de l'influence cette
proposition de loi est issue d'un
premier travail transpartisan à
l'Assemblée nationale travail que je
tiens à saluer tant qu'il porte sur un
sujet d'actualité et toujours en
développement le marché de l'influence
commerciale pour rappel quelques
éléments de contexte sur les objectifs
en fait de cette proposition de loi un
de mieux faire connaître le secteur de
l'influence au grand public au monde
institutionnel parlementaire et
politique et ce alors que les
publications des influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux font partie de notre
quotidien cette proposition de loi
rappelle également les règles
applicables à la publication de contenu
promotionnels et publicitaires sur les
réseaux sociaux l'objectif étant de
mieux sensibiliser et responsabiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur à
leurs obligations je parle de l'ensemble
des acteurs je parle des influenceurs
des agents des marques et des sponsors
elles visent également à identifier les
particularités liées à cette pratique
commerciale et déterminer ainsi dans la
loi les règles spécifiques qui devraient
s'appliquer aux promotions et publicités
effectuées sur les réseaux sociaux
l'objectif de cette loi un des autres
objectifs en tout cas de cette loi et
d'accompagner la structuration et la
professionnalisation d'un secteur
relativement récent bien sûr en plein
développement et source aussi de
croissance économique et d'innovation
enfin et j'aurais pu j'aurais dû
commencer par cela cette proposition de
loi a pour ambition de protéger les
consommateurs ont limitant au maximum
les risques d'arnaque d'escroquerie et
de pratiques commerciales déloyale donc
avec une attention particulière pour les
jeunes publics plus vulnérables
puisqu'il est opportun de rappeler que
70% des adolescents de 12 à 17 ans
utilisent régulièrement les réseaux
sociaux madame Magalie bardah nous vous
additionnons donc aujourd'hui en tant
qu'influenceuse et agent d'influenceurs
pionnière dans le milieu de l'influence
commerciale votre connaissance votre
expérience nous intéresse tout
particulièrement dans cette phase
d'examen de cette proposition de loi au
Sénat nous souhaitons de vous écouter
précisément sur votre vision le secteur
de l'influence son évolution ce que vous
pensez évidemment de la proposition de
loi
en examen de l'opportunité de structurer
de professionnaliser le secteur de
l'influence commerciale je vous cède
sont plus tarder donc la parole et vous
remercier encore de vous être rendu
disponible pour cette audition qui
durera à peu près 30 minutes et je vais
vous demander par recommencer par en
tout cas nous expliquer parler de votre
parcours et de ce qui vous a amené à
devenir dans un premier temps
influenceuse puis agent d'influenceurs
je vous remercie alors merci beaucoup
pour pour cette accueil et merci de me
recevoir aujourd'hui
et bien écoutez moi j'ai fondé cette
société en 2016
j'ai rencontré des candidats
télé-réalité au départ qui faisait
beaucoup de promotion pour des marques
mais sans vraiment avoir de rémunération
c'était vraiment à titre en échange de
de produits par exemple où les marques
leur offraient des vêtements en échange
d'une publicité
et de là avec un regard effectivement un
peu plus
business on va dire moi je leur ai
demandé mais pourquoi vous faites pas
rémunérer parce que je considère que si
une marque fait du bénéfice grâce à vous
il est normal que vous soyez aussi
rémunéré pour pour l'apport de que vous
leur faites en chiffre d'affaires ce qui
est totalement logique à mon sens et
j'ai observé un petit peu ce qui se
passait aux États-Unis comment ça
fonctionnait les codes promo etc et je
dois dire que je me suis beaucoup
inspiré de ce modèle américain
et je l'ai développé sur ces
influenceurs là qui était totalement
ouvert à le faire vraiment avec toute
transparence
c'est à dire que on voilà il y avait
aucun souci à dire qu'ils étaient
rémunérés etc c'était vraiment clair je
leur ai créé des adresses mail qu'on a
mis sur leurs réseaux sociaux sur leur
compte Instagram donc où je
réceptionnais des demandes de
partenariat
j'ai commencé à négocier leur premier
contrat donc j'ai commencé aussi m'a
conseillé la plupart d'entre eux à créer
une entreprise puisqu'ils allaient
encaisser des rémunérations donc soit en
auto-entreprise soit en société donc on
a commencé à structurer ça à ce niveau
là également
on a
littéralement explosé parce que ça a
porté une visibilité nouvelle au marque
et surtout aux petites entreprises parce
que un petit une petite comparaison par
exemple quand vous faites une publicité
en télé où vous allez toucher un million
et demi de personnes bah ça peut coûter
50 60 000 70 000 euros et aujourd'hui
les petites entreprises en France qui se
lancent par exemple n'ont pas les moyens
de se faire connaître et l'influence ça
permet aussi à toutes ces petites
entreprises là ça leur a permis de se
faire connaître de développer on a aidé
énormément de marques à se développer
qui aujourd'hui sont vendus
même en grande surface ou en pharmacie
par exemple pour des marques de
shampoing pour des marques de beauté
donc c'était vraiment un succès
et ça c'est vraiment hyper bien
développé voilà donc
de là et nationavent et puis et puis
après on a fait notre petit chemin et
j'ai vendu la société en 2018 un gros
groupe audiovisuel que
qui a été propriétaire de cette société
pendant 4 ans et là après tous les
récents événements j'ai préféré
reprendre mon indépendance et
sortir voilà sortir du groupe et faire
ce que j'aime faire c'est à dire
accompagner les influenceurs et puis et
puis aider les marques à se faire
connaître parce qu'à la base notre
métier c'est ça aussi c'est d'aider
toutes ces petites entreprises toutes
ces marques à agrandir et à évoluer et
ça a été vraiment un succès je tiens à
le dire alors après au début c'était
nouveau donc c'est vrai que on s'est un
peu on a des fois été dépassé un petit
peu par tout ça donc j'ai tapé à la
porte de la RPP en 2017 où je leur ai
demandé des conseils j'y suis allé
volontairement leur demandant en leur
disant voilà j'ai ouvert une société ça
marche j'ai de la demande ça n'arrête
pas mais je sais pas vraiment ce que
dans quel cadre en fait où est-ce que je
dois aller à qui qui va me conseiller à
quoi je dois adhérer est-ce que c'est la
publicité est-ce que c'est pas de la
publicité donc on m'a vraiment gentiment
répondu la RPP ont été vraiment à mon
écoute m'ont donné beaucoup de conseils
m'ont expliqué que ils étaient en train
d'étudier ce phénomène justement aussi
que il fallait être soumis alors c'est
pas vraiment de la publicité parce que
il y a une différence légale entre le
mannequin et l'influenceur qui est très
important et ça c'est la base déjà de
cette enfin pour moi de cette loi c'est
que l'influenceur a une liberté de
communiquer parce que justement il est
là pour utiliser son sa façon d'être
c'est pas un mannequin où on guide en
fait et on lui dit de faire ça comme ça
telle heure etc donc il faut vraiment
garder ce côté naturel ils m'ont tout de
suite dit qu'il fallait indiquer le
l'effet sponsorisé c'est à dire de dire
consommateur que c'était une promotion
rémunéré donc nous il est vrai que chez
Shana Evans on a vraiment pas eu ce
genre de problème parce que on a indiqué
tout de suite dès 2017 à nos
influenceurs sur chaque brief qu'il
fallait qu'ils mettent le hashtag
sponsorisé sur toute leur publications
donc on n'est pas vraiment concerné nous
par ces ces les récentes condamnations
qu'il y a eu qui concerne pas les
influenceurs qui ont été liés enfin les
promotions liées à notre agence
et on a un peu appris sur le tas
voilà donc
justement je vous en prie dans la
continuité de ce que vous êtes en train
d'évoquer je vais m'arrêter un peu sur
justement avant de parler même d'agents
d'influenceurs
métiers évoqué bien sûr dans cette PPL
sur la fonction d'influenceurs en
elle-même vous l'avez dit ça s'est
construit en allant avec oui parfois des
difficultés puis même surtout une
structuration qui s'est faite sur le tas
qu'est-ce qui explique selon vous la
trait des jeunes
auprès déjà de ce métier là puisque
beaucoup de jeunes le pratiquent et
qu'est-ce qui explique aussi ce fort
impact de
du métier du secteur de ces techniques
en fait d'influence auprès des jeunes
particulièrement puisque pour rappel 70%
de nos ados de 12 ans à 17 ans
aujourd'hui vont sur les réseaux sociaux
bien sûr alors les réseaux sociaux
effectivement sont voilà il y a on le
sait c'est la jeunesse qui est enfin
voilà c'est un milieu où la jeunesse
évolue avec avec nos réseaux sociaux qui
peuvent être des fois très et
extrêmement dangereux je pense qu'il y a
une énorme responsabilité à voir aussi
des plateformes qui doivent surveiller
ce qui s'y passe je pense que si les
plateformes ne sont pas remplies
impliquées
ben en fait on y arrivera pas très
clairement je pense qu'il faut qu'il y a
des réunions avec les plateformes tant
sur les sujets enfin surtout les sujets
qu'on peut rencontrer sur le web enfin
sur les réseaux après il y a une on va
dire une une rupture entre les jeunes et
les médias traditionnels
qui ou les jeunes qui vont chercher les
informations sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que peut-être que le langage est
plus facile à comprendre il est plus
moderne il est plus plus adapté à eux en
tout cas les influenceurs effectivement
sont suivis par des jeunes parce que ils
savent leur parler également
moi je l'ai vu par exemple quand j'ai
fait les campagnes présidentielles où
j'ai été interviewé les candidats à la
présidentielle c'était des questions qui
étaient simples et compréhensibles pour
tous en fait c'était vraiment un petit
pas vers la politique pour essayer de
ramener la jeunesse à ça donc on sait
que les influenceurs ont un impact sur
J'aime maintenant je tiens à vous
préciser que l'influence commerciale
alors il y a l'influence non commerciale
pour moi qui est celle-ci mais il y a
aussi l'influence commerciale donc qui
est tout aussi importante qui ne doit
pas s'adresser aux jeunes puisque les
jeunes
c'est pas le la cible on va dire de
c'est comme c'est comme la télévision
c'est à dire qu'en fait il cible
déménagère les marques cibles des
ménagères par exemple et
il faut faire effectivement très
attention à ce qu'il dit sur les réseaux
à ce qui se vend tout comme à la
télévision ou dans d'autres médias parce
que effectivement maintenant on a un
outil nous qui est très bien c'est que
sur les réseaux sociaux on arrive à voir
la cible
des influenceurs c'est à dire que sur un
influenceur on arrive à savoir combien
de pourcentage il a de moins de 18 ans
combien de pourcentage il a de 20 à 30
ans de 30 à 40 ans donc on arrive à
savoir donc un influenceur aujourd'hui
commercial entre guillemets qui a 80 %
de jeunes en dessous de 18 ans je dirais
que c'est pas ce que recherche les
marques de toute manière voilà là je
parle en influence commerciale
toujours sur cette notion d'influenceurs
que beaucoup découvrent en fait encore
aujourd'hui je voulais dire l'enjeu
c'est aussi une pédagogie une
compréhension en fait de ce phénomène
d'influence commerciale comment on
devient influenceur et comment on
devient agent d'influence je parle pas
de votre propre parcours mais comment ça
se passe concrètement techniquement
alors techniquement tout le monde peut
devenir influenceur dans le sens où à
partir du moment où la personne a un
talent pour fédérer une communauté quand
la personne a un talent pour pour que
les gens c'est pour moi c'est un vrai
talent en diabolise souvent les
influenceurs en France et c'est assez
triste parce que aujourd'hui réunir des
millions followers et les tenir tous les
jours c'est un talent on a beau dire ce
qu'on veut et
donc il y en a qui arrivent à être
influenceur sans avoir forcément et il y
en a pour tout le monde fait de télé il
y a des influenceurs qui sont issus de
la chanson à partir du moment où on a
une communauté qui est engagée on est
influenceur et pour être influenceur et
là où il y avait c'est vraiment un vide
juridique c'est qu'à ce jour le statut
d'influenceur juridiquement n'existe pas
il y a pas de code APE donc on tape sur
un métier aujourd'hui en France qui
quelque part n'existe même pas parce que
quand vous voulez être influenceur et
bien vous allez soit créer une société
soit aller à l'URSSAF vous inscrit en
tant que entrepreneur mais il y a pas le
statut le code APE influenceur et ça
c'est important parce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre là ils ont sorti des chiffres
récemment disant qu'il y avait 150000
influenceurs j'arrive pas à savoir
comment ils peuvent calculer le nombre
d'influenceurs alors qu'on peut même pas
les identifier légalement à
l'inscription déjà à l'URSSAF en tant
qu'influenceur donc donc la loi en parle
d'ailleurs ils ont mis ce statut en
place et ça je trouve que déjà c'était
la première des choses à faire
voilà
parfait agent d'influenceurs
concrètement ça consiste en quoi alors
agent influenceur c'est bah déjà mettre
en relation une marque avec un
influenceur négocier au mieux les
contrats pour protéger les influenceurs
pour protéger les consommateurs pour
protéger aussi les intérêts de la marque
puisqu'on représente aussi quelque part
une marque ou qu'on est au milieu de cet
écosystème
et c'est aussi ben conseiller les
talents à créer du contenu maintenant
pour moi une agence d'influence n'est
pas forcément une agence de production
et encore une fois un influenceur pour
moi doit être capable de créer du
contenu alors avec l'aide d'une agence
bien évidemment mais aussi parce qu'il a
le talent de le faire nous on n'est pas
des fabricants moi je reçois beaucoup de
mails de jeunes par exemple ou de gens
qui me disent je veux être influenceur
prenez-moi dans votre agence etc mais
c'est pas aussi facile que ça il faut
que la personne et elle-même un talent
et nous on sera là pour l'accompagner
juridiquement pour l'aider pour le
conseiller et pour on a fait ce travail
d'ailleurs chez shonayvent en 2018 de
créer un service juridique pour faire
attention aux marques qu'on valide et de
dire attention ça c'est pas légal ça
c'est en fait on a un travail qui va
au-delà de ce qu'on est censé faire au
départ ou alors on est juste là pour
négocier normalement des contrats mais
on se retrouve à devoir faire plus parce
que internet c'est dangereux
vous l'avez vu dans cette proposition de
loi on parle de contractualiser la
relation entre l'influenceur et la gente
influenceurs qu'est-ce qui avec quelques
préconisations sur le contenu en fait de
ce contrat qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui
quels sont les obligations pardon qui
doivent lier en fait l'influenceur de
l'agent d'influenceurs qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui les lie ben nous on a un
contrat avec chacun des influenceurs
alors on a deux types de contrats on a
des contrats à type enfin de type
exclusif c'est à dire que le
l'influenceur est en exclusivité dans
l'agence et ne peut pas normalement
faire de postes en direct avec les
marques par exemple malheureusement
[Musique]
souvent ce n'est pas respecté
et il y a un autre type de contrat qui
est non exclusif où on a des des
influenceurs indépendants à qui on
ramène des marques de temps en temps
mais qui peut aussi se servir dans
d'autres agences ou en direct avec les
marques c'est là où il y a un amalgame
aujourd'hui justement sur ce qui se
passe dans les fameuses polémiques c'est
que malheureusement les gens ou
certaines personnes identifient telle
influenceur telle agence donc tel
placement telle agence et en fait
souvent c'est pas le cas c'est pour ça
que les contrôles de la DGCCRF sont très
importants parce que le contrôle de la
DGCCRF va pouvoir donner
est-ce que ce contrat là a été passé par
l'agence ou pas et après la DGCCRF fait
son travail correctement mais il y a
rien de mieux pour moi que ces
enquêtes-là qui qui sanctionnent les
personnes qui doivent être sanctionnées
et pas jeter en pâture une personne
on prévoit donc d'écrire dans la loi
cette obligation de contrat tout à fait
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le cas ce n'est pas systématique parce
que vous connaissez de ce qui se
pratique aujourd'hui est-ce que une
majorité de
d'influenceurs sont tenus par des
contrats avec leurs agents leurs agents
ou est-ce que est-ce que des gens la
majorité des influenceurs ont des agents
alors aujourd'hui oui la majorité des
influenceurs ont des agents je pense que
c'est très bien d'avoir une agence parce
que l'agence va être équipée justement
juridiquement pour s'en cadre enfin pour
être encadré nous on voit là par exemple
dans les polémiques la plupart des des
postes qui ont été sanctionnés souvent
ne sont pas reliés aux agences et ça ça
n'a pas été vraiment dit et c'est un
problème parce qu'il faut que ce soit
très clair parce qu'il faut que enfin on
sert aussi à quelque chose et il faut
que les influenceurs le sachent
voilà maintenant
c'est c'est
quels sont les principales dérives
rencontrées pas de votre situation je
parle de vraiment dans le secteur de
l'influence quels sont les dérives
possibles des influenceurs des agents
d'influenceurs je pense que il y a deux
types de dérives il y a la dérive par
méconnaissance parce que aujourd'hui on
est vraiment lié que au code de la
consommation mais c'est à la fois très
grand parce que le code de la
consommation est très grand et il faut
être honnête pas tout le monde ne le
connaît par coeur et pas tout le monde
n'a cette analyse je pense qu'il y a un
problème de formation
pour nous tous
donc on essaie de faire du mieux qu'on
peut pour s'entourer et être encadré
maintenant
les influenceurs voilà pour moi doivent
faire des formations pour être
aux personnes parce que tout le monde
peut être influenceur aujourd'hui vous
pouvez avoir 18 ans comme 20 ans avoir
un bac + 5 ou pas avoir de bac du tout
et vous pouvez être influenceur donc
forcément vous n'avez pas la
connaissance de toutes les règles et
toutes des lois
donc il faut il faut les former et
surtout qu'Internet est un milieu vaste
ou vous avez tellement de dérives
tellement de dérives c'est à dire qu'on
a rencontré par exemple alors par
exemple il y a le dropshipping le
dropshipping c'est quelque chose de
légal mais où il y a des dérives
malheureusement il y en a beaucoup plus
que de bonnes que de bonnes fin de
personnes qui sont qui font du
dropshipping correctement donc là ça a
créé beaucoup de problèmes mais quand on
s'en aperçoit bah des fois c'est souvent
trop tard donc est-ce qu'il faut
interdire le dropshipping ou pas ça
c'est pas de mon ressort mais
effectivement il y a eu des problèmes
donc dans les agences après on a décidé
d'arrêter le dropshipping comme ça au
moins on préserve après il y a eu des
gens qui se sont mis tous dans les paris
sportifs après il y a eu le trading
après il y a eu la NFT après il y a eu
les CPF là en ce moment il y a des
choses sur les pare-brise par exemple en
fait il y a j'ai l'impression que sur
internet il y aura toujours des gens qui
sont malveillants qui vont trouver une
faille pour
mettre en application leur dérive à
travers des sites internet et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit accompagné
là-dessus pour
être prêt à ce genre de choses et avoir
des alertes immédiates voilà
de secteurs ou de dérive problématique
dans cette proposition de loi sont
évoquées aujourd'hui des interdictions
oui par exemple celle de la chirurgie
esthétique mais pas comme un meilleur
encadrement de jeux qu'en pensez-vous
est-ce qu'il y a selon vous dans le
marché sur le marché de l'influence dans
le marché de l'influence commerciale des
secteurs des activités à interdire alors
oui je pense alors après faire de la
mois de ce que m'avait appris la RPP
quand j'étais allé les voir en 2017 la
promotion de chirurgie esthétique est
déjà interdite normalement donc mais je
pense que c'est bien de le rappeler
effectivement dans une règle pour que
les influenceurs soient beaucoup plus
qu'ils aient une loi pour eux parce que
c'est tellement vaste comme je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure le Code de la
Consommation qu'il le connaît souvent
pas par cœur du tout et on peut pas
reprocher ça non plus donc c'est très
bien d'avoir cette règle qui rappelle
ses lois mais à la base s'élo elles sont
déjà faites mais c'est bien de les de
les concentrer dans une règle exprès
pour les influenceurs je pense que voilà
mais oui il y a des choses qui doivent
être claires aujourd'hui on peut pas
travailler avec un milieu où on est
rempli d'amalgames un coup un coup c'est
légal un coup c'est pas légal on sait
pas il y en a qui se tape dessus il y en
a qui balancent les autres il y en a non
il faut que les règles soient
applicables à tous que ce soit les
agences les influenceurs que s'ils
règles ne soient pas piquées il y ait
des sanctions pour éviter ces amalgames
et qu'il y ait enfin un travail serein
je suis bien placé pour le pour le dire
puisque je suis la première à être
sur les fronts de toutes ces polémiques
malheureusement pointées du doigt à la
place de tout le monde
et personne en prend trop ses
responsabilités donc j'avais déjà il
faut que vous le sachiez aussi
alerter le cabinet du ministre Bruno Le
Maire en 2021 parce que le métier c'est
c'est vraiment diversifié et ce qui est
normal ça prouve qu'il est en bonne
santé il y a beaucoup de concurrence de
plus en plus et j'ai senti tout de suite
que il y avait un peu du coup du tout du
n'importe quoi mais comme mon agence
était connue et que entre guillemets moi
aussi bah c'était tout le temps mon nom
qui ressortait partout donc je m'étais
permise d'écrire à Bruno Le Maire en lui
disant voilà est-ce qu'on peut faire un
rendez-vous parce qu'il y a des dérives
il faut mettre des règles en place on a
besoin d'être encadré on a besoin de
peut-être créer une association
interprofessionnelle j'avais tout listé
par écrit ils l'ont reçu puisqu'ils
m'ont répondu
j'ai su récemment qu'à l'époque puisque
c'est eux qui ont communiqué là-dessus
ils ont dit que à l'époque c'était pas
leurs urgences ce que je peux comprendre
aussi
mais bon malheureusement aujourd'hui ben
on est dans un dans un dans une
situation qui est délicate tant pour
nous tant pour les influenceurs tant
pour les agences et tant pour moi
personnellement avec ce que je subis à
côté en cyber-harcèlement donc vous
estimez qu'à aujourd'hui il y a
nécessité c'est ce que vous
recadrer oui c'est une question vitale
pour moi personnellement là je parle de
mon cas à moi c'est une question vitale
et j'aurais aimé qu'on le prenne en
considération quand je l'avais demandé
il y a quelques enfin il y a maintenant
deux ans où j'avais demandé des
rendez-vous à plusieurs reprises pour
alerter les autorités et pour dire on a
besoin de règles claires pour que tout
le monde les applique et que et que les
personnes qui sont responsables soient
condamnés il y a pas de sujet voilà
c'est
bien qu'il faut structurer il faut tout
à fait professionnaliser il faut former
ce que vous avez d'autres préconisations
pour justement mieux encadrer
j'ai donc
j'ai créé la fille que il y a quelques
temps effectivement parce que dans la
loi il n'y a pas de oui c'est la
Fédération des influences et les
créateurs de contenu parce que c'est
quelque chose donc j'avais soumis l'idée
aussi de par écrit en 2021 quand j'avais
écrit au cabinet du ministre parce que
je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait une une
un groupement il faut que je pense que
tout le monde travaille ensemble on
vient tous d'univers différents c'est ça
aussi la magie des réseaux sociaux c'est
qu'il y en a pour tout le monde c'est la
diversité des réseaux sociaux il y a des
gens qui ont comme je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure une culture plus importante
que d'autres il y a des gens qui sont
plus expressifs que d'autres il y a il y
en a vraiment pour tout le monde
et donc il faut pas sous-estimer les uns
ou les autres il faut que tout le monde
travaille ensemble pour créer des règles
et il faut accompagner les influenceurs
il faut que les agences aussi soient
accompagnés et ces formations qui ne
sont pas dans la loi par contre et ça
c'est dommage elle elle soit presque
obligatoire et surtout moi j'avais eu
l'idée donc je vais le faire dans la
fille mais je pense que ça aurait été
bien de le faire avec l'aide de des
députés c'est de créer comme un code
de bonne conduite des influenceurs comme
peuvent avoir certains métiers voilà il
y a des ordres de dans certains métiers
parce qu'on a des responsabilités
aujourd'hui qui sont prouvées donc
où on peut avoir par exemple des
avertissements ça peut arriver de faire
une erreur on est des êtres humains
l'influenceurs est un être humain il
faut pas l'oublier donc on peut faire
une erreur une fois deux fois trois fois
mais quand vous avez un influenceur qui
fait systématiquement les mêmes erreurs
alors que il a les formations alors
qu'il a les informations là c'est plus
une erreur et là il faut qu'il y a une
radiation et c'est pour ça que les que
les les
autorités les agences travail
étroitement avec les plateformes
pour qu'il y ait un apaisement de la
situation et que ce soit sain et que
tout le monde travaille dans de bonnes
conditions je reviens sur votre votre
initiative de créer la fique vous en
êtes concrètement en fait de cette fête
mon numéro d'immatriculation que dossier
a été déposé il y a un petit moment
maintenant donc ça va pas tarder j'ai
déjà plus d'une centaine à ce jour
d'accord de principe de d'adhésion
d'influenceurs j'ai demandé aussi à
quelques lanceurs d'alerte j'ai demandé
à des avocats aussi
pour que tout le monde puisse travailler
ensemble et qu'on puisse construire
quelque chose de propre
autre question et je suis entourée de
collègues surtout n'hésitez pas si vous
avez des questions sur sur la
différenciation entre le canal de
communication commerciale
entre les réseaux sociaux et puis les
autres canaux de communication tels que
la presse la télévision etc est-ce que
selon vous il faut distinguer les règles
applicables dans ces différents cas de
communications est-ce que le canal de
communication des réseaux sociaux pour
vous doit avoir un traitement différent
oui je pense qu'il doit avoir un
traitement différent parce que déjà
encore une fois on a pas les mêmes
règles ce n'est pas légal aujourd'hui en
télé par exemple quand vous faites une
pub en télé vous faites appel à des
mannequins donc ils ont un script à
réciter une tenue à voir un endroit
enfin c'est un tournage alors que en
influenceur et c'est ça le rôle d'un
influenceur et c'est vraiment une
différence légale importante que m'a
appris la RPP au départ quand j'ai
commencé et que j'explique à mes
influenceurs c'est que l'influenceur
doit être libre de son contenu c'est à
dire que je ne peux pas exiger un
influenceur voilà tu dois faire ton
poste à telle heure tu dois dire ça
exactement tu dois en fait ce n'est pas
un mannequin c'est pas du tout de la
même la rémunération n'est pas la même
ça n'a rien à voir donc il faut séparer
ça et surtout il y a un élément
important c'est que en télé par exemple
vous ne pouvez pas aujourd'hui passer
une publicité en télé sans qu'elle soit
validée par la RPP alors forcément il y
a pas de problème en télé aujourd'hui
mais si ils ont mis cette vérification
au départ elle a bien été mise à un
moment donné cette vérification c'est à
dire que une marque qui paye une pub en
télé ne peut pas être diffusée si elle
n'a pas la validation de la RPP donc
c'est qu'ils savent très bien qu'il y a
des problèmes et qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une validation
juridique on va dire avant diffusion
pour pallier justement à des des fois et
en influenceur non dire que nous on est
totalement libre personne ne nous valide
quoi que ce soit alors c'est très bien
ce qu'on a influenceur mais ça prouve
aussi que on a peut-être besoin d'avoir
des codes beaucoup plus clair et des des
explications beaucoup plus claires
peut-être des validation peut-être
travailler il y a il y a un souci dans
notre milieu où il y a
je dirais comme un
vous savez comment comment je peux
m'exprimer on prend de haut certaines
agences on prend de haut certains
influenceurs et du coup on ne nous tend
pas la main on ne nous aide pas on aide
d'autres alors que chez nous par exemple
on a des gens qui ont des millions de
followers donc qui ont un impact qui est
immense et on doit être traité comme les
autres c'est pas parce que une personne
influenceur a fait de la téléréalité que
il ne doit pas être traité de la même
manière que les autres et ça c'est un
vrai problème dans ce milieu aujourd'hui
l'initiative parlementaire cette PPL
exprime quand même la prise en compte
très claire d'un phénomène qui n'est pas
si récent que ça vous l'avez rappelé et
en effet répond en tout cas à certaines
des certaines questions ou difficulté
que vous évoquez je vais donner la
parole à mes collègues va se présenter
et vous se mettra ces questions
je suis sénateur d'Ille-et-Vilaine je
voulais vous poser une question parce
que il y a l'agent il y a un contrat il
y a un influenceur
pour bien voir où on peut peut-être
avancer vous dites que l'influenceur
n'est pas un mannequin et donc il a une
grande liberté
et dans ce cas là où est-ce que où est
la responsabilité lorsqu'il y a des
choses qui sont contraires
pourraient appeler je sais pas comment
on peut l'appeler mais une espèce
d'éthique de la publicité où est la
responsabiliser chez l'influenceur ou
est-ce qu'elle est chez l'agent comment
vous voyez comment pourrait construire
ça alors moi je pars du principe ou une
agence doit servir à quelque chose et
j'ai pas d'intérêt à vous dire ça mais
je vais je il faut être honnête si on
prend une commission sur les
influenceurs c'est aussi parce qu'on
doit leur apporter quelque chose donc je
pense que cette aide juridique est
importante c'est à dire que si on donne
un placement de produit frauduleux à un
influenceur l'agence doit aussi être
responsable et c'est pas dans mon
intérêt de le dire mais c'est une vérité
et c'est une réalité l'agence si elle
donne un placement elle doit être aussi
responsable influenceur aussi
responsable parce que c'est trop facile
de dire c'est l'agence c'est l'agence
moi je sais que on a eu des influenceurs
qui nous ont dit moi je fais tout et
n'importe quoi et puis on a des
influenceurs qui nous ont toujours dit
non ça je ne fais pas c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'on fait nous on propose aux
influenceurs les sites internet donc on
les valide d'abord au juridique ensuite
on les propose aux influenceurs et les
influenceurs disent oui ou non ils ont
une totale liberté sur ce qu'il propose
donc si l'influenceur n'a pas envie ou
ne se sent pas de présenter ce produit
là il a la liberté de dire non mais si
il dit oui et que il se trouve que c'est
un placement frauduleux alors dans le
cas où l'agence parce qu'il peut aussi
que l'agence était trompée ça nous est
arrivé aussi ou on a vérifié le site il
était légal tout était carré les
conditions générales étaient parfaites
tout est nickel vous faites la promotion
de ce site et le site ferme une semaine
après dans ces cas-là qui est
responsable l'agence qui a tout contrôlé
où tout est nickel ou le site internet
qui est venu dans la volonté d'arnaquer
les gens et y compris l'agence puisqu'on
a même pas été payé non plus des
prestations donc je pense que à ça
doivent servir aussi des enquêtes et des
des enquêtes de la DGCCRF ou si on
promotionne un site qui n'est pas
juridiquement
légal il y a une responsabilité de
l'agence à avoir voilà mais si le site
est légal après on peut pas non plus
être derrière la tête des gens enfin
derrière la tête de tout le monde c'est
pas possible c'est c'est clair voilà
mais il faut qu'on propose des sites
carrés voilà et chacun doit assumer ses
responsabilités
ça permet de cerner en partie mais
chacun ses responsabilités justement il
y a un moment il faudra trouver qui
assume quoi ça c'est je pense que si
l'agence donne un placement de produit
qui est pas légal l'agence est
responsable voilà très clairement c'est
c'est moi je suis si jamais si par
exemple j'ai un de mes influenceurs qui
est condamné pour un placement de
produit que je lui ai donné à faire et
que il m'a fait confiance et bien je
trouverai ça normal que l'agence par
exemple paye sur maintenant si c'est
l'influenceur qui fait en placement de
produit qui n'est pas passé par l'agence
moi je n'ai rien à voir là-dedans voilà
et entre l'exclusivité
vous allez aborder le public des jeunes
au début de votre propos
public forcément beaucoup plus
vulnérable
comment voyez-vous la relation des
influenceurs et des agences
d'influenceurs par rapport à cette au
mineur mais je pense que encore une fois
dans une dans une influence commerciale
on ne doit pas s'adresser aux mineurs
vous voyez ce que je veux dire déjà à la
base c'est comme et là je vais comparer
ça à la pub à la télé c'est pareil vous
avez de la pub à la télé il se trouve
qu'il y a des jeunes aussi qui vont
regarder la pub à la télé et qui vont
peut-être vouloir acheter le produit qui
vont voir à la télé comme ils vont ils
vont le voir aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux donc on peut pas non plus être
derrière tout le monde ça sera c'est pas
gérable mais
dans l'influence commerciale qui est
différente de l'influence on va dire de
de de notoriété de conseils etc ces deux
choses différentes l'influence
commerciale et l'influence non
commerciale dans l'influence non
commerciale il faut que chacun fasse
attention à ce qu'il dit sur les réseaux
parce qu'effectivement ça a des
conséquences on s'en est rendu compte à
plusieurs reprises beaucoup plus qu'on
peut le croire et je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention effectivement à ce
qu'on dit ou est-ce qu'on fait sur les
réseaux sociaux ça c'est une certitude
maintenant dans l'influence commerciale
encore une fois
on s'adresse pas aux jeunes et encore
moins aux enfants qui normalement enfin
je dirais à quelqu'un un enfant de 12
ans on n'est pas censé avoir peut-être
une carte bleue pour pouvoir on peut pas
être responsable non plus faut que tout
le monde soit un petit peu responsable
aussi à ce niveau là
de la Somme moi je m'interrogeais avec
ce texte
cetpl notamment sur le volet en 1 sur
les voilà les bandeaux qui seraient
imposés comme quoi c'est une publicité
etc déjà avoir votre avis parce que je
sais qu'il y a déjà des problèmes
techniques sur le changement quand on
change de canal et de réseaux sociaux je
sais qu'il peut avoir des problèmes
juste purement esthétiques pour faire
apparaître ce bandeau mais ça ça je
pense que les plateformes vont aussi
évoluer en ce sens mais au-delà de tout
ça je
m'interrogeais aussi sur le le notamment
le bouquin de
Delphine de Vigan sur les enfants sont
rois je sais pas si vous vous voyez
c'est une femme qui justement qui se
lance influenceuse et qui embarque ses
enfants dans cette aventure c'est-à-dire
que ces enfants sont filmés H24
et à la fin il y a une espèce de conflit
dans la famille à partir comme ça parce
que les enfants ont rien demandé disons
après ils se rendent compte que
effectivement ils sont passés dans dans
différents canaux réseaux sociaux ils
ont rien ils ont rien demandé à personne
et pourtant c'était j'ai envie de vous
dire le gain de pain de de la famille en
question donc sur ces sujets pour
rebondir un peu sur la question de mon
collègue c'est vrai que sans le vouloir
une influence un influenceur ou une
influenceuse même si elle a 25 30 ans et
qu'elle embarque
indirectement ses enfants là-dedans
est-ce qu'il y a une pas aussi quelque
chose à
réglementer encadrer en particulier je
pense que les agences n'ont pas à
prendre ce type de profil
les agences ne doivent pas prendre les
enfants et ça c'est quelque chose aussi
qu'on a mis en place c'est à dire que
dès qu'on a une marque qui demande une
promotion où les enfants doivent
intervenir ça doit passer par une agence
de mannequin spécialisée pour les
enfants c'est à dire que nous on ne peut
pas encaisser les contenu dans d'un
enfant ça c'est ce que nous nous faisons
en tout cas chez shona even après je
sais pas pour les autres agences mais
effectivement il faut faire attention
moi les enfants c'est quelque chose pour
moi qui est vraiment
spécial et qu'il faut gérer d'une
manière totalement différente et qui ne
doit pas du tout être géré la même
manière que un financeur adulte c'est
une évidence et je vous rejoins
totalement
voilà et là ils en ont parlé dans le
texte de loi je crois qu'ils ont mis
quelque chose là-dessus et c'est très
bien mais quoi qu'il avant nous les
enfants ça nous est arrivé je crois
peut-être quatre fois en presque 7 ans
d'avoir des demandes pour les enfants et
systématiquement on a passé ça à une
agence de mannequins spécialisée pour
enfants donc qui encadrent vraiment bien
l'enfant sur les avec la loi qui va avec
en fait voilà
et puis un autre point tout à l'heure je
vous disais je vous parlais du bandeau
qui voilà des espèces d'encadrement là
dessus
il y a quelque chose qui va qui est en
train de se faire discrètement c'est en
fait
beaucoup d'influenceurs vous voyez que
ça va comment le marché va être un peu
près encadré par ce type de VPN avec le
DSA DMA etc
il rentre en discussion avec les
personnes donc c'est beaucoup moins je
vous l'accorde industriels que des
vidéos qui sont vus par des millions de
personnes mais ceci dit il rentre en
discussion donc en privé avec les
personnes créer un lien et derrière
vendre les prestations et donc ça bon
c'est compliqué à encadrer je vous
l'accorde mais est-ce que c'est pas
est-ce que c'est pas ça ce qui va se
passer c'est à dire que beaucoup
d'influenceurs vont basculer ce genre de
méthode je je peux faire le test si vous
voulez je il suffit de suivre quelques
influenceurs 48 heures après vous pouvez
éventuellement peut-être ça dépend votre
propre niveau d'influence aussi
avoir une discussion juste pour essayer
de vendre une prestation ou une la
crypto monnaie la copie de trading etc
etc
on en fait pas donc je suis pas dans ce
domaine là et et je le maîtrise pas et
ça ne m'intéresse pas parce que c'est
quelque chose que justement je pense que
je ne maîtrise pas et aucun conseil à
donner là-dessus et je pense que mes
influenceurs non plus donc maintenant
c'est plutôt dans ce genre de choses où
vous allez effectivement sur des comptes
télégrammes etc ça c'est c'est un autre
type d'influence mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui nous enfin qui me concerne moi
parce qu'on fait pas on fait pas ça
enfin je parle via l'agence show nevens
ça n'est pas le cas
nous on fait des promotions visibles sur
les réseaux sociaux où on parle d'une
marque on parle d'une expérience avec
une marque on parle d'un produit
voilà on donne un avis on montre comment
ça fonctionne et on met le hashtag
sponsorisé sur chaque story alors au
départ on le mettait pour être
transparente avec vous on le mettait au
moment de mettre le code promo et on
était une des seules agences à le faire
depuis 2017 parce que comme vous dites
comme là tout le monde se rend compte
qu'il va y avoir des règles tout le
monde se met à le mettre partout et tant
mieux c'est que ça marche donc mais on
nous tape souvent dessus nous shonven
mais nous étions les premiers depuis
2017 à mettre le hashtag sponsorisé et
maintenant il va falloir mettre sur
toutes les stories qui la promotion et
non pas que au moment du code promo et
il ne faut pas et ça il faut être clair
avec les influenceurs parce qu'il y en a
certains qui qui comprennent pas et qui
mélange encore un peu ça c'est que
certains mettent le hashtag add mais le
hashtag add ce n'est pas pour la
Communauté française parce que c'est pas
français donc un consommateur n'est pas
censé savoir ce que ça veut dire add il
faut mettre vraiment hashtag sponsorisé
moi c'est ce que m'avait conseillé aussi
la RPP pour que ce soit clair
transparent et pas en tout petit cachet
dans un petit coin il faut que ce soit
visible voilà une dernière question je
m'interrogeais sur le votre déficience
tout à l'heure entre votre volonté de
différencier les mannequins et les
créateurs de contenu
vous surfez aussi là dessus dans cette
dans cette vision là je suppose mais moi
je m'interroge quand même sur
le les limites de cette définition parce
qu'en réalité un bon un créateur de
contenu quand il fait de la publicité il
a
l'obligation de sortir un slogan en lien
avec la on va dire la pub qu'on
l'oriente en tout cas le produit qui va
vendre donc il y a quand même le slogan
de la marque qui sort donc il sent avoir
un script tout fait etc mais
peut-être qu'il crée son on va dire son
son univers et mais à la fin il finit
par le slogan de la marque pas forcément
mais
alors je vous explique on reçoit comme
ça moi vous le savez on reçoit des
briefs des marques on les transmise
influenceurs mais le brief n'est pas une
obligation c'est à dire que le brief
c'est juste on l'envoie aux influenceurs
il s'en inspire et ils font le contenu
qui veulent c'est pour ça que des fois
on a des litiges avec des marques qui
nous disent l'influenceur n'a pas
respecté le brief mais il n'a pas
respecté le brief l'influenceur il peut
s'inspirer du brief mais il le fait à sa
manière et c'est ça souvent que même les
marques ne comprennent pas parce que les
marques elles se disent on veut le brief
et alors des fois on a eu des soucis
avec des marques finalement je vais pas
vous payer parce que vous n'avez pas
respecté le brief mais nous le travail a
été fait parce que l'influenceur a parlé
de la marque à sa manière comme il
entendait pas le droit de lui dicter un
code à tel point de dire je ne le paye
pas ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
c'est pas ça un influence un influenceur
il doit être libre donc effectivement on
envoie des briefs mais l'influenceur a
le droit de juste s'en inspirer et de
faire à sa manière et c'est là où il y a
une différence avec le mannequin et s'il
n'a pas envie de dire la phrase de A à B
et ben on peut pas l'obliger à le dire
et la marque dans ces cas-là doit faire
appel à un mannequin voilà
quasi dernière question
dans nos échanges et souvent évoqué la
situation des influenceurs qui résident
hors de France qui s'adresse à un public
français et d'ailleurs dans la
proposition de loi il est évoqué en fait
un contrat qui serait soumis en fait au
droit français
qu'en pensez-vous est-ce que vous vous
travaillez avec des influenceurs qui
résidents de France oui tout à fait je
travaille des influenceurs qui réside à
l'étranger
il y a quelque chose aussi de très fort
sur les réseaux sociaux comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure par rapport à
l'âge par exemple c'est aussi vous avez
la cible un influenceur il a des
statistiques et dans ces statistiques
vous pouvez voir si la majorité de son
public est français vient de quel pays
en fait on a ces éléments là qui sont
visibles sur les réseaux sociaux donc si
effectivement la majorité des influences
des des followers sont français
évidemment pour moi il y va du bon sens
qu'effectivement ça s'applique au droit
français voilà donc
je pense que c'est un peu logique à ce
niveau là
est-ce que vous avez d'autres éléments
d'autres à ajouter dans le cadre de
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
je pense que c'est cette proposition de
loi elle est elle est très bien je pense
qu'il manque dedans vraiment des des
éléments sur les formations
alors il y a la RPP qui a créé un
voilà un certificat mais le certificat
on va le passer une fois et comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure internet
est un monde grand vaste et avec plein
de de mauvaises pensées c'est à dire que
comme je vous l'expliquais il peut y
avoir ça va être ça puis après ça va
être une autre arnaque après une autre
arnaque ils ont l'esprit très vif donc
je pense qu'il faut avoir une
déformation en continu et pas des formes
juste un certificat il faut vraiment
encadrer les influenceurs en continu et
leur apprendre
et les alerter et les sensibiliser sur
les nouvelles les nouvelles fraudes
parce que c'est toujours on a
l'impression après c'est ce que j'ai pu
moi remarquer pendant ces 7 années
d'expérience c'est qu'en fait c'est
c'est voilà c'est le drop le paris
sportif après ça s'arrête le pari c'est
le trading après le trading ça s'arrête
c'est la NFT après la NFC ça s'arrête
c'est le CPF on sait peut-être un peu
tous fait avoir dans plein de choses
mais je pense que si on était alerté
aussi
ça et nous les CPF par exemple on a on
en a parlé sur nos réseaux sociaux comme
comme quasiment beaucoup d'influenceurs
on peut pas cibler que les enfants sur
télé réalité parce que ça c'est
mensonges il y a énormément
d'influenceurs qui ont parlé de CPF de
tout milieu et
nous on a eu enfin moi j'ai entendu
auprès d'une personne
qui travaille un peu dans les autorités
attention il y a des sujets sur les CPF
nous on a entendu ça déjà au mois de
janvier l'année dernière quand on a
entendu qu'il y avait des sujets sur les
civettes ça veut dire qu'il y avait des
gens qui étaient en train d'abuser et
bien on a stoppé l'argument commercial
CPF avant même toutes les polémiques on
a fait un une alerte à tous nos
influenceurs en disant attention ne plus
parler de CPF on veut plus que le CPF
soit un outil un argument commercial
donc ça on l'avait fait bien avant et on
l'a prouvé d'ailleurs on a donné tous
les justificatifs à la Caisse des Dépôts
etc bien avant les polémiques parce que
on a eu connaissance mais si tout le
monde avait eu connaissance de ça
peut-être que finalement tout le monde
aurait fait la même chose ça aurait
permis peut-être d'éviter certaines
choses donc il faut des formations
continues je pense
ça changera beaucoup de choses